problema 52 carmen resolvió la ecuación
2 x 12 x + 5 es igual a 8 usando los
siguientes pasos y aquí ponen algunos
pasos vamos a leer la pregunta para ir
del paso 2 al paso 3 carmen ok ok
entonces queremos ver qué hizo carmen
del paso 2 al paso 3 entonces estaba en
4x igual a menos 2 y paso a x igual a
menos un medio bueno pues para pasar de
aquí a acá lo que estamos haciendo es
dividir entre 4 a ambos lados de la
igualdad verdad para que este 4
desaparezca dividimos aquí entre 4 y
aquí también entre 4
aquí se cancela el 4 con el 4 y nos
queda que x es igual a menos 2 cuartos
pero eso se simplifica a menos un medio
entonces carmen dividió entre 2 ambos
lados entre 4 perdón y además simplificó
esta fracción vamos a ver cuál de las
opciones concuerda más con eso la opción
a dividió a ambos lados entre 4 si eso
suena bien a lo mejor falta ponerlo de
simplificar pero bueno esto suena bien
vamos así palomita vamos a leer las
demás resto cuatro de ambos lados no
definitivamente no sumó cuatro a ambos
lados pues tampoco multiplicó ambos
lados por cuatro no pues mucho menos y
hubiera quedado 16 x menos ocho verdad
entonces éstas suenan que no son
entonces debe ser a dividió a ambos
lados entre cuatro y además simplificó
bueno vamos ahora el problema 53 que es
el último de este examen de práctica nos
preguntan cuál es el recíproco de a x al
cuadrado entre y esta pregunta también
está fácil como la anterior simplemente
tenemos que recordar que que es el
recíproco y el recíproco de un cierto
algo simplemente es uno entre ese algo
sí tenemos x el recíproco es uno entre x
si tenemos una fracción es voltear la
fracción si es a entre b él recibió el
recíproco sería b entre a si tuviéramos
no sé xy entre
el recíproco sería k l
/ ec y si sale lo que nos dan aquí es a
x al cuadrado entre y a x al cuadrado
entre y de modo que su recíproco su
recíproco sería h / a x al cuadrado y
esa es la opción de y con esto
terminamos este examen de práctica